il va falloir sont des questions sur la
cuisine vous allez devoir manger la
réponse or à chaque fois celui qui a
mangé la réponse qui a fini la réponse
d'accord il est il est qualifié il y
aura un éliminé à chaque fois la mode
made man made man man et à la fin il
n'en restera qu'un voici la première
question vous jouez avec nous bien sûr
que non selon un term propre aux gens
qui ont l'humour non par exemple
isabelle morini-bosc côte il n'a pas de
problème il n'y a pas deux y'a pas de
quoi le circuit de soucy beebeejaun
celle ci est complètement souci je sais
qu alors je sais qu'à date n'aime pas
les sur le poisson cru local gâte et
éliminé d'office ou chez moi j'ai mon
seul souci est elle réellement je ne
dirai qu'elle en dégustation c'est
sûrement là
alors j'ai deux contraints de faire un
petit trou du haut-pays moment là non
mais c'est ça vous avez mais c'est vrai
j'ai un petit trou du couple samedi
tous avaient un petit coin un petit trou
du coup mais depuis tout petit et ça me
donne un vrai que vous avez quelle est
l'autre nom de la foudre quel est
l'autre nom de la
[Applaudissements]
j'ai en entier
alors
j'ai mangé un bout mais après senna va
ça va moi j'ai leclerc à brive bush et
bien il aura mangé au mans 38 brown aura
qualifier bayrou c'est pas la petite
bête qui va mal mais bon début mais j'ai
mis le souci qui est crédité large pays
ne sera pas là dedans il des trucs qui
me va manger ou qui pose un petit peu
courtois pareloup voilà merci là bas at
an plus tôt je vais vous dire de la moc
est disqualifié à hawija la madeleine on
dit souvent que matthieu delormeau a
pris le pas les melons
non j'aime ou j'aime le melon volonté de
finir le melon finir leur plaît allez
prenez tout le monde le melon c'est bon
vous allez crever arrêté arrêté jeudi
alors on n'est pas avec un goûter avec
les motards c'est cécile verrait allait
y aller alors qu'est-ce que vous criez
lorsque vous fait mal c'est non
jean-michel de la qualité j'ai une
qualité c'est morrow qualifié qu'à
syndicalisés mon mini boss qualifiés et
nora ces bombes rues larges et vous êtes
disqualifié à doha ne mangez pas merci
j'en ai pris
quel est le nom du piquet qui sert à
fixer une dans une tente de camping dans
le sol une série c'est un débrayage
bon c'est bon t'as toujours merci
éliminé isabelle mans il y va tous les
reculs et vont reculer
merci lorsqu'on est au bord de la colère
qu'est ce qui nous donne et c'est ce que
nous avons tourné
et sont malades c'est bon j'ai un peu
ouais c'est bon aussi
c'est une route des sanguinaires
on apprécie t compléter l'expression
suivante on n'attrape pas les mouches
avec du vinaigre
c'est jules hallez et chez les mots qui
chantent en finale
puis on a découvert la semaine dernière
que sur le pied jean-michel l'air avait
sonné au niger en avoir c'est juste un
morceau le plus c'est jules vallès la
gagner je suis désolé l'écueil séduit
verdasco vainqueur quoi